Welcome to unit 11. At this point, I hope everyone's feeling pretty confident
that you can write programs that can do interesting and powerful things. We've
come a long way, but we still don't know how to unleash our programs on the
world. At this point, to run your programs, you need to run them in the Python
interpreter. What we're going to learn in this unit is how to write programs
that we can unleash on the expectant world. To do that we need know a little
bit about input and output. Being able to make programs that other people can
use is very empowering, but it also requires being careful. Once other people
start using our programs, well, they might do things wrong. Even worse they
might be malicious. They might intentionally create inputs to our programs that
try to make our programs do bad things. So, we have to be a lot more careful
when we construct programs for other people to use.